for Part II because we just read off
sandy what did you measure what did you
mean oh yeah I measured two millimeters
as well so therefore um the distance er
so you got a super awesome ruler right
maybe you can get more accuracy than
mine I've only got millimeters okay so I
went 0.2 centimeters and I'm x 400 like
I've been doing okay so watching out for
your decimal places what's that going to
be yeah 80 centimeters or or zero point
yet exactly or zero point eight meters
is fine okay okay now when you get to
party I've now got to combine some
measurements right I've already been
given a width there 7.2 meters so now
I'm going to have to measure this
distance ER and combine them where do
you see you see where I'm trying to flow
now you can go ahead and you can
calculate that yourself there's a couple
of steps they're out there or maybe
three we measure with that measurement
which I assume will be like in
centimeters is that company what are you
gonna do with that you're gonna have to
convert once you've converted the
question actually wants an area so then
thirdly it's yet the area of a rectangle
right so it's like post breath okay
that's fine but it's not as unusual as
it sounds because yeah well I would be I
would actually expect does anyone know
they don't want to have a hazard a guess
why is there a border here I but the
pipes for people to
yeah sure I would say there's that's
plausible safety I'd say fire I'd say
fire actually because in a school I
happen to know there's a minimum
distance that buildings have to be next
to each other because what would happen
if there was fire and all other goodies
like right next to each other the fire
just goes straight across right Liz
murder there's no gap between them okay
now in in reality here because there's
trees there I don't think it's got a
function very well as a barrier but
council regulations are all about this
right you generally have trees up to a
certain height if trees are below said
how you know lamb chop them down etc so
actually it's not that unusual I don't
think that the garage has this little
matter ok now I'm going to skip over the
mid because you get to a few questions
that are just about measurement because
you can I Bok min left but I'm ok
have a look carefully for Part F no gee
sorry to calculate a total length of the
pool fences look carefully where are
these provinces where are they very good
for blue lines around the pool you've
got one that's already been given to you
then you're gonna have to measure this
one and this one I think this one's also
given to you isn't it yeah it's also
given to you right there I think cuz I'm
just checking I don't think this
distance is given to you right so
therefore I'm going to have to get my
rule out again measure it out and then
include it with the other ones hey it's
that make sense yeah yeah you can do it
that way because you've already worked
that out in fact let's do that let's do
that so I'm going to call this length
here let's give this a name so that we
can stop talking about this link that
leg all you like me to call it how about
H it's a height or on my diagram it's a
high ok if it's H and I'm measuring it
in meters because everything else has
already been given to me remember I've
got the two meters over here the four
meters over here we had it suggested
that we've already worked out I'll put
it in red we've already worked out this
length because you mention it and
earlier on you also measured that link
because you also measured it right let's
have a look we wrote it down didn't we
that little distance was was 80
centimeters point eight of a meter has
someone measured the garage and
converted 1.1 Asia really
I got 1.2 I think yeah well this is the
thing right this is so we're going to be
we're get our site different on this but
that's okay that's all right let's go
well I'm here 1.1 a lot okay so for Part
Jean Shh once you measure 1.1 that means
you actually get from that something in
meetings right what do I have to do
again I've got 2 x 400 400 so I'm going
to do this h it's going to be 20 take
away what are the two things i'm
subtracting there's the 0.8 which is
between the garage and the fence and
then you just told me that this distance
here is 1.1 centimeters on the plan
what's that in reality it's 4.5 meters
very good ok so I'm going to combine
those together I've subtracted this zero
point eight I should subtract the 4.4 as
well so what does that give us get
someone calculate it 20 take away
point 8 14.8 what's he playing yeah now
that's just one of the fences right
that's one of the fences so i'm going to
say total fence because I've got to
include all the other ones is the 14.8
that you guys just told me and then
there are the other two nights which
we've just been given in the diagram if
you come back you can see there's the
four right there it's a bit small and
then there's the two up there so plus 4
plus 2 that six looks to me like 20
point eight meters what do you think you
see it yeah this year the port the
process we went through ok I'm happy
with that yeah yeah sure ok so that was
an extra thing so what we did was we
measured the garage right we measured it
and what we found was on the drawing it
was 1.1 centimeters but in reality it's
400 times bigger than that right so then
I had to multiply that by 400 which
gives me four point here is ok all right
up yes H I and J H I J if you have a
look at them they all have to do with
the pool so we should consider them
together think we've got no space you it
says calculate the area of land taken up
by the pool through the nearest square
meter you've got your diagram in front
of you do we need to measure any of the
pool with our rule
so it has a curvy beer right now then
having not said anything else I think
it's okay to assume that that's a
semicircle okay so therefore I've got a
rectangle on the top this guy and then
I've got a semi circle on the bottom
okay to work out the area of a
semicircle what distance and I going to
need out there I'm going to have to use
that for meters at the top that's a
diameter I don't usually use diameter
for my area for me though yeah I usually
use the radius which is two ok all right
so let's make out this pool then the
area of the pool is there's a rectangle
the dimensions of the rectangle are look
at your map look at your plants are four
by eight so I four by eight and then
you're going to add on half of a circle
a semicircle that's half of pie and us
Tommy the radius was 2 x 2 square yep
with that a lot of this we can do with
our heads 4 by 8 is 32 you've got a half
a pie at a four so that's going to be 2
pi and now I actually need my calculator
right 2 pi is like six point something
or other so want to actually punch that
inform each yep so when we add that 6.28
to 32 it's going to be thirty eight
point two eight dot dot it looks like
they want it to the nearest square meter
so I'm going to round that off and i'm
going to say i'm rounding it to the
nearest square meter like so okay now
plot iron plot J are moving from that to
volume to capacity and they go pretty
easily together so for Part I this is
the cross sectional area ya got the
bird's eye view we're looking at from
right down and they told us you've got
an average depth so i'm going to say
volume equals that 38 that we just said
times that average depth that's what
to I should point out this is all still
approximate but it looks like it's going
to be what 40 45 45 EF so about 46 it
doesn't said a theorist it hasn't given
us a new your shooter but I'll go stay
with the new students we had before so
if i had 45.6 ago an approximate their
246 what units is this is a volume cubed
very good so this is to the nearest
cubic meter last one for the pool and
I'm going to get you to train to Kate on
your road find the amount of water so
this is a capacity question so I'm going
to go from volume to capacity and they
helpfully remind you that a cubic meter
attributed really big right a cubic
meter has a thousand liters of water in
it as you can see down there in the
question so what am I going to have to
do with the previous number it's pretty
simple i just multiplied by a thousand
right so it's 46 by that key lolita
there so there's my number